if you feel like you are the output of
your life like at the end of your life
who you are is the thing that is the
thing that you became then competition
is good for you like if you look back at
that person would you want that person
to have no challenges like if you were
at the end of your life and you looked
back would you be like I'm glad I
overcame no adversity I'm glad no one
ever put me to the test I'm glad I never
got to see what I was truly capable of
you would never say that we just don't
like going through it in the short term
but we do want the outcome of it and so
I think that if you just accept that
that's the price tag for the person you
want to be then you just pay it
willingly